Welcome to week 3 in the Robotic Vision Project.
The objective for this week is to get our
image of our robot vision worksheet in MATLAB
and then, segment the particular 2D shapes
into a color that being either red, green
or blue. I've written a function in MATLAB
that allows me to do this so let's take a
look at the outputs of this week in our MATLAB.
Okay, so in MATLAB here, I already have the
robotic vision worksheet loaded so let's take
a look at that quickly.
Okay, so the robotic vision worksheet is here
as you can see and the task this week is to
take the image I have here and then, segment
it according to the particular color channel
that you're interested in.
So, that will allow you to specify what 2D
objects they want to appear in your image.
So, you either want to get the red 2D objects
or the green 2D objects or the blue 2D objects.
So, the output is going to be a thresholded
or binary image of what you started with.
Now, I've written a function that allows me
to do that and I've called it getColor. So,
let's see how my getColor function works.
So, let's say I wanted to segment the red
2D objects using my function. How would I
do that?
Well, I need to make a new variable and I'll
call it R2D and then, I'll call my function
which is getColor and my particular function
takes in 2 variables.
The first is the robotic vision worksheet
which is img and the second parameter is a
color so I can specify either red, green or
blue to segment the particular 2D objects
of that I'm interested in and you can see
that that is produced a R2D variable on the
side here and it is logical.
So, it's a binary or logical image. So, let's
take a look at what that looks like. So I
will call, idisp(r2d) and then, I can have
both of these images up the same time.
So, you can see on the left hand side, we
have our original robotic vision worksheet
and on the right, this is my segmented image
and you can see that only the red 2D objects
are highlighted.
Okay, so it's a binary image. We either only
have black or white on here and the white
are the red 2D objects.
So, this is a task for you guys to do this
week: Create a function similar to my getColor
function that allows you to produce a segmented
binary image of a particular color channel
that you're interested in.